اذا مشاهدينا شكرا لخالد ونستمر معكم في
هذه التغطيه انا ميسون عزام احييكم تطورات
متصاعده يشهدها السودان حاليا بعد اندلاع
اشتباكات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
هذه الاشتباكات بدات من محيط القاعده
الجويه في مروي ومن ثم انتقلت الى داخل
العاصمه الخرطوم ومحيط العاصمه امتدت ايضا
الى محيط مقر اقامه البرهان وحمدتي والقصر
الرئاسي ومن ثم الى التلفزيون الرسمي ادى
تلك الاشتباكات الى سقوط ثلاثه قتلى
مدنيين واصابه العشرات الجيش اعلن عن
تدمير اكثر من 80 مركبه عسكريه تابعه
لقوات الدعم السريع في مرويه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
على كل المزيد معنا من مدينه مروي ينضم
الينا مراسل العربيه نزار بقطاوي اهلا بك
نزار انقل لنا اخي المعلومات المتوفر لديك
تفضل
لك التحيه اخر المعلومات التي تحصلت عليها
قناه العربيه قبل قليل عن مصادر عليمه
بالجيش السوداني هنا في مروي بان الجيش
السوداني الان اطبق سيطرته كامله على مطار
مروي الدولي والقاعده العمليه العسكريه
هذا ما اكدته قيادات عسكريه قالت ايضا
بانها وجهت نداء لكل من يتبع لقوات الدعم
السريع بتسليم الاسلحه او مغادره المنطقه
فورا هنالك من استجاب وهنالك من لم يستجيب
استجاب لتسليم الاسلحه والمغادره نزار اذا
لديك معلومات
نعم البعض استجاب والبعض غادر في اطار
الكروه الفرد هذا النداء لا يشمل مروي فقط
وانما يشمل كل المناطق التي حدثت فيها
اشتباكات خلال الساعات الماضيه ايضا من
التحديثات التي يجب ان تذكر في هذا الاطار
بان بعض القاده العسكريين اشاروا فيما
اشاروا الى ان الدعم السريع الان يتحرك
خارج اطار ما يوصف عسكريا بانعدام
المؤسسيه او قياده السيطره على الميدان اي
انهم يتحركون في شكل مجموعات دون تلقي
معلومات من مركز قياده موحده هذا ما اشارت
اليه بعض المصادر العسكريه عندما تحدثنا
اليها الان قبل قليل كانت هنالك اعمده
اعمده للدخان ومتصاعده من داخل قاعده مريم
الجويه واستمعنا ايضا كذلك الى ارتفاع
وتيره الضربات والضربات المضاده للاسلحه
للاسلحه الثقيله والمباطات داخل قاعده مرو
العسكريه هذا يشير الى ان الامور الان
بدات تمضي نحو طور الحسم هذا ما يشار الى
جانب المعلومات التي تحصلنا عليها قبل
قليل نضيف ايضا كتحديثات اخباريه ومعلومات
بان عدد المصابين الذين دخلوا الان الى
المرافق الصحيه تحديدا مستشفى مروي
العسكري ما بين 30 الى 45 من مصابي الجيش
السوداني خلال هذه الاشتباكات التي تطورت
الى عمليه عسكريه خلال الساعات الماضيه
مجتمعينا الجميع هنا في مروي يتابع وينظر
ويراقب مالات وتداعيات هذه العمليه
العسكريه المستمره منذ الساعه التاسعه من
صباح هذا اليوم وما زالت مستمره حتى الان
ننتظر ونترقى وصول قوات عسكريه علمنا
بانها تحركت من مدينتيشندي وعبر وايضا من
العاصمه الخرطوم في طريقها الى شمال
السودان تحديدا الى مروي تحت عنوان حسم
التحركات التي تمت من قبل الدعم وحتى تصل
هذه المجموعات حجم الاشتباكات واين تتمركز
نزار
معظم اجل الاشتباكات داخل قاعده المروي
العسكريه هي مساحه كبيره تقدر باكثر من 18
كيلو متر مربع داخل المطار الى جانب
القاعده العسكريه الى جانب وجود الطائرات
الى جانب وجود القوات البريه والقوات
الجويه فضلا عن وجود قوات الدعم السريعه
التي يقدر عدد المركبات هذه القوات
والسيارات باكثر من مئه مركبه وسياره هذا
هو سؤال
عندما يقول الجيش السوداني انه سيطر على
المطار وعلى القائد العسكريه ولكن انت
تقول ان الاشتباكات لا زالت بالداخل طبيعه
هذه السيطره بالمفهوم الجيش السوداني
طبيعه هذه الاشتباكات ربما تكون بعض
العناصر كما علمنا ايضا من قبل الدعم
السريع ما زالت في محيط قاعده مروي تحاول
ان تمارس عمليات الضرب من البعد وثم تقترب
الان هنالك عمليه عسكريه هنالك حرب في
منطقه معينه هي قاعده مروي العسكريه هذه
المنطقه تحتمل الضرب من القرب وتحتمل
المناوله العسكريه من على البعد كل هذه
السنرات هي ما يجعل هذه الاشتباكات
متواصله حتى هذه الساعه من عصر هذا اليوم
عندما بدات طبعا هذا يدلل لماذا تستمر
الاشتباكات هي تبدا وتنخفض تنخفض وتبدا
اعمده الدخان تتصاعد من المناطق التي شهدت
عمليات غزيره لاطلاق النار واطلاق
المدفعيه والمدفعيه الثقيله هذا هو الموقف
حتى اللحظه في مدينه مروي يمكن ان نلخصه
وان نجمله هل لدينا معلومات او امكانيه من
التاكد حول من يسيطر على الخطاب الاعلامي
الان
الكل الان هذه حرب الحرب الان
مشروع فيها كما يفهم من قبل سياقات هذه
العمليه منذ الصباح استخدام البيانات ليس
هذا اليوم حتى قبل اربعه ايام قبل ان تنشف
هذه الصراعات وهذه العمليه
البيان الجيش السوداني يخرج البيان الان
منذ الصباح قوات الدعم تخرج اكثر من بيان
الجيش يصرح الان كل جهه تنفذ في ارض
الميدان هي من تريد ان تؤكد على موقفها
وتريد ان تقول باننا نحن على وجه السيطره
البيانات تخرج من جهتين من جانب الجيش ومن
جانب الدعم السريع ماذا عن المؤسسات
الرسميه الاعلاميه نزار
ما رشح لدينا من معلومات في الخرطوم هنالك
التباس حول الموقف من الاعلام الرسمي
تحديدا التلفزيون الرسمي والاذاعه
السودانيه بحكم وجود قوات الدعم السريع
لاكثر من طعام في هذه المنطقه هي موجوده
وكانت تشرف على تامين هذه المنطقه الى
جانب وجود عناصر من الجيش السوداني اما
هنا في مروي فالخطاب الاعلامي هو ما ينقل
الان عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ليس
هنالك من خطاب رسمي الان موجه في هذه
المنطقه عادا المعلومات التي تنقل عبر
القنوات التي تنقل وتبث الاخبار من
الولايه الشماليه وكيف تسير الحركه في
الشارع تقول فيه هدوء في مخاوف في
اشتباكات بمناطق دون غيرها ماذا عن
المناطق الهادئه وهل هناك من توقعات ان
تتوسع رقعه هذه الاشتباكات او لا اصبحت
محصوره في تلك المناطق
الجيش السوداني كما
انما الى علمنا
يعرف العمليه العسكريه داخل الى محيط
القاعده والى داخل المدينه هو يعمل على
ذلك لانه نشر عتاد وقوات عسكريه على
السياج المحاذي لمدينه مروي المطله مباشره
على هذه القاعده هذه القاعده مطله مباشره
على بعد اكثر من 500 متر فقط ومنها مباشره
الاحياء السكنيه في مدينه
مروي بشمال السودان الجيش يعمل على حد هذه
الاشتباكات لا تذهب بعيدا المواطنون الان
الكل في منزله السوق الرئيسي مغلق المحل
التجاريه مغلق المؤسسات الرسميه مغلقه عدا
المستشفى العسكري الذي يستقبل جرح
العمليات او العمليه العسكريه دون ذلك
الان هنالك حاله من الصمت حاله من الهدوء
حركه محدوده للغايه داخل مدينه مروي الكره
الان يتابع مباريات الاحداث ونحن نتحدث عن
ساعات ليليه مقبله لا يعرف ما هو شكل
السيناري وهل تصاعد ام انخفاض لهذه
الوتيره العسكريه التي بدات صباح اليوم هل
لدينا اي معلومات عن وسطات فاعله على
الارض الان او لا
هنا على الارض
تنشط الخليه الامنيه العسكريه
الاستخباراتيه داخل القياده الفرقه
التاسعه عشر هنا ترتيب امني ترتيب عسكري
ترتيب استخباري اما على اطار المبادرات
حتى الساعات الاولى كنا على علم بمساعي
وصفت بانها حميده لرابه الصدى لنزع فتيل
الازمه لكن مجرد ان اطلق الطلقه الاولى
داخل مطار مروي الدولي يبدو ان هذه
المبادرات اصبحت في عداد الماضي وليس لها
من تاثير ربما تنشط الان لجنه راب الصودا
هنا في الشماليه التي تحوي قيادات
قوميه وقيادات معلومه لكن بطبيعه الحال
هذا الامر تمدد خارج مروي واصبح في
الخرطوم وعدد من المدن
شكرا جزيلا لك من مدينه مروي كان معنا
مراسل العربيه نزار بقداوي
على كل ايضا من الخرطوم ينضم الينا رئيس
حزب الامه القومي السوداني اللواء فضل
الله بالمناصر اهلا بك لواء فضل الله اسمح
لي ان ابدا
بموقفكم الرافد لما يحدث على الارض ولكن
هل تحملون المسؤوليه لجهه دون غيرها
نعم نعم نحن طبعا
موقفنا الراصد مش رافض عبثا راصد
حقائق
تجري لاشياء لا تحمد لانه
الان السودان بمر بمرحله حساسه ودقيقه في
حياته لم يشهد في تاريخ السياسه المعاصر
شيء لواء فضل الله انت تشاهد الان
بشاهده
بيموتوا في افنانكم مؤشرات مؤشرات خطيره
عواقبها تكون
على وحده السودان وامن واستغراب
الحرب الدائره الانديه اذا استمرت عواقب
وخيمه
انها خطيره على وحده السودان
السودان واسع ومتنوع وقبائل
معدل تتعلمون ذلك
الخطر على
والخطر على امن السودان واستقراره
وانه
ما لا يتمناه انسان لوطنه
بالتالي انا بقول السنان لانه الحارس
الحارس صباحا اليوم ده
وقول انه مؤسف لانه
دماء السودان
من ابناء السودان
ولا احد يريد ان يرى مثل هذا المشهد ولكن
خبرني اكثر عن من يتحمل المسؤوليه فيما
يحدث من هو المستفيد لصالح من هذه
المواجهه
ان النظام السابق هو السبب متمثل بمن
متمثل بمن
حزمه السابق المؤتمر الوطني
ومعهما راودهم الذين نقبوا السودان واكلوا
بمص صدم السودان
والايام بيتطلعونه بالصوت العاليه نحن
نعود للحكم ومسلم قم 30 سنه
يمكن لهم خلينا نقرا الواقع على الارض كيف
لهم ان يعودوا
لواء فضل الله ان يعودوا الى السلطه كما
يقولون من خلال هذا الصراع ما بين الجيش
السوداني وايضا ما بين الردع السريع ولكن
اسمح لي الدعم السريع عذرا اسمح لي ان
نستمع الى هذه الاصوات واعود اليك
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا هذه صور خاصه للعربيه من
كاميرا العربيه من العاصمه الخرطوم وصوت
للاشتباكات وايضا الدخان يتصاعد من
استهدافات لبعض المباني الموجوده تحليق
للطيران وايضا قصف بالمدافع اذن ذوي
اشتباكات في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم من
خلال هذه الصور المباشره والخاصه من
العربيه عود اليك لواء فضل الله وكنت قد
سالتك عن المستفيد من هذه المواجهه
وبالمقابل عندما تحمل النظام السابق
المسؤوليه هو متمثل بمن من خلال ما نشهده
من صراع ما بين الجيش وما بين الدعم
السريع تفضل
حمل سياسي
يقوم به اعضاء النظام السابق الذين فقدتم
وبداوا في هذه الايام قمت قم بانفسهم
يعلنون باننا نحن عائدون ومش نحكم 30 سنه
قلت
التركيبه السودانيه هشه للغايه
[موسيقى]
اما الصعب بقدر صعب
لكن لا يستطيعوا ان يعودوا للحكم الا عن
طريق
عن طريق الفوضى
الفوضى وهم يعودون كيف خلقوا هذه الف
وضى محل
الدعم السريع يتهم الجيش بانه هو من غدره
والجيش يقول لا التحرك الاول كان من قبل
الدعم السريع فكيف استطاع تحريك من
النظام او اعضاء النظام السابقه الفلول
موجود في القوات المسلحه
30 سنه 30 سنه
داخل القوات المسلحه
عملت لها انظمه
القوات المسلحه
عملت الدعم السريع السلطه الشعبي اعمل
الدعم الشعبي الدفاع الشعبي امر الشرطه
الشعبيه عملت الامن عملت قوات موازيه لكل
القوات النظاميه
وبالتالي على انها لا تستطيع بني
الانتخابيا ان تعود ولا تستطيع انها ترجع
للسلطه
وهذه الفوضى التي تتحدث عنها لواء فضل
الله نحن نشاهدها من خلال تحرك الدعم
السريع هذا ما تقوله بمعنى اخر بانه لا
ياخذ
اوامره او قراراته من حمدتي او انه هو جزء
ايضا من المؤامره
حبيبتي الفاضله في حرب في نهايتها شنو
الحرب حاجه بعد ما فيها منتصر معزوم
حرب اهليه
السودان بتركيبته
سوداء قبائل سودان نظام اجتماعي يختلف
اقتسلاندا فوق اختلاف في اللغات وفي
عاداته في ثقافات
ولكن هذا تبعات لما حدث ولكن من اشعل فتيل
ما حدث ومن يتحمل المسؤوليه هاي النقطه
الرئيسيه ومن قام بذلك هل يمكن ان نقول من
بدا بمثل
بما حدث هل يمكن لنا ان نقول بانه كان
يدري بان هذه هي النتيجه كان مسير بمعنى
اخر يتخذ الاوامر او انه في فرضيه كانت
غائبه لم يكن يدري مثل ان تصل الامور الى
ما وصلت اليه او الى حيث تتجه
الان التعاسه موضوع يعني انا لا اقول على
انه كانت الاوضاع بين القوات المسلحه
والدعم السريعه انها هي تتامر الدعم
السريع والقوات المسلحه وقعوا معنا على
الاتفاق المبارك
وقع معانا المجتمع الدولي وعلى اساس
تعود القوات المسلحه الى سكناتها
ويعود نظام الحكم الى السلطه المدنيه
وعملنا نحن ورش كثيره واخر ورشه كانت ورثه
الاصلاح الامن العسكري
تمت العمليه بتاعه الاصلاح الامن الاصلاح
والتحديث بطريقه
ولكن كمان مربط الفرس ان عمليه دمج الدعم
السريع في القوات المسلحه
[موسيقى]
والمجتمع الدولي يقول ست سنين
والولد
الاتفاذه النهائي الفوقه الدعم السريعه
الكلام ده كان كله ناس ممكن تجي تقعد
ويقول اثنين زائد
خمسه زائد عشره على ثلاثه وكل حاجه يصرف
لكن هنالك هنالك هنالك من قال انه
ما يجزع ويشتغل خلف القواليس
وسنتابع التطورات نعم من الخرطوم رئيس حزب
الامه القومي السوداني اللواء فضل الله
يرمى
ناصر شكرا جزيلا لك
وننتقل الى تصريحات رئيس مجلس السياده
الانتقالي في السودان الفريق عبد الفتاح
البرهان له تصريحات خاصه للعربيه قال فيها
ان المتمردين من قوات الدعم السريع سعوا
للسيطره على مقرات الجيش والمناطق الحيويه
فجرا البرهان اضاف متمردون دعم السريع
خططوا لتنفيذ اغتيالات وان خيار الجيش
الوحيد هو التصدي لمطام من وصفهم
بالمتمردين في السلطه عبد الفتاح البرهان
قال ان الجيش يدير عمليه ضد المتمردين
بصبر وذلك لمنع وقوع اي خسائر بشريه واكد
البرهان ان الجيش السوداني لديه قوات
كافيه واراده لدحر هؤلاء الاشخاص
المزيد معنا من الخرطوم مراسل العربيه
سالم الهاشمي اهلا بك سالم نشاهد صور
مباشره الان من قلب العاصمه الخرطوم
ونستمع الى ذوي اطلاق نار انفجارات لا
اعلم تحليل طائرات انقل لنا المشهد من
عندك ما الذي يدور واين هي تلك المنطقه
تحديدا
نعم
الانويه الانفجارات والتواصل اطلاق النار
وكذلك المضادات الطيران والطيران الذي
يحلق في سماء الخرطوم متواصل
الان في شتى
انحاء الخرطوم لكن
اللافت هنا ان كان هذا جاء بعد ان توقف
يعني عشر دقائق تقريبا توقفت
قليلا كانت هناك القليل يشبه حضنه يعني
والان عاده من جديد هذه المشاهد التي
نشاهدها هي في الخرطوم في المناطق التي
تطل على خلف مستشفى الخرطوم
التخصصي من خلفه وفي هذه المناطق مناطق
حيويه جدا قريبه من القصر الرئاسي قريبه
من الوزارات من مجلس الوزراء من القياده
العامه للجيش وتظهر ايضا في الصوره كل هذه
الصوره تعبر عن منطقه حس افه جدا في
الخرطوم وفيها اشتباكات عنيفه وايضا تتجول
العديد من
الدبابات في هذه المناطق ونحن نتحدث عن
اشتباكات ولكن لا نتحدث عن سيطره الدعم
السريع ايا من هذه النقاط الرئيسيه سالم
الاشتباكات لا تحدد ما الذي يسيطر من عدم
السيطره لكن هناك ومن هنا مصادر لنا
قوات الدعم السريع سيطره لدعوه التلفزيون
سيطرت على دبابه موجوده في مبنى الاذاعه
والتلفزيون هناك ضرر كبير في الاخبار ثم
تم ضرب هذا الاستديو بالكامل استديو
الاخبار للتلفزيون القومي السوداني في ام
درمان ايضا انبات تتحدث عن سيطره قوات
الدعم السريع على القاعده الجويه في جبل
الاولياء سيطرتم على مطار مئويه
حتى مطار الخرطوم كل هذه الامور
تحدث الان نحن الان ما زلنا نسمع دوريه
الانفجارات
من فتره واخرى حتى هذه اللحظات يعني واضحه
من خلال هذه الصور التي ننقلها مباشره
بكاميرا العربيه على دعني اشير الى
تصريحات اخيره للخطوط السعوديه حول
الطائره التي قالت انها تعرضت لحادث في
الفجر في التفاصيل الخطوط السعوديه تقول
ان الطائره تعرضت لاطلاق نار وذلك في مطار
الخرطوم وعلامتها كان من المسافرين وطبعا
الطاقم كان متواجد هناك طبعا بعد هذا
الحادث اعلنت الخطوط السعوديه عن وقف
رحلاتها من والى السودان تبعتها بعد ذلك
شركه ناس وايضا الخطوط المصريه
وهذا وايضا اضافه الخطوط السعوديه انه تمت
اعاده طاقم الطائره المتضرره الى السفاره
وذلك في الخرطوم وطبعا نوافيكم بالمزيد من
التصريحات وحول الاصابات يمكننا سؤالك
سالم ان كان هناك محصله للاصابات عدد
الوفيات جراء الاشتباكات
نعم المحصله الان هي في ازدياد في الحقيقه
للاسف الشديد كل دقيقه او دقيقتين يزداد
هذا العداد بتسارع مخيف جدا في شتى مناطق
السودان من اصابات خطيره من عدد الوفيات
نفسه الوفيات الان تجاوزت العشرات تستطيع
ان نقول في شتى مدن السودان ايضا الاصابات
تجاوزت المئات حتى هذه اللحظه ونتحدث عن
ارقام المدنيين فقط وليس للعسكريين هذه
ارقام للمدنيين هنا في بحر فقط الان اكثر
من 30 اصابه في المستشفى الدولي منها الان
26 اصابه توفيت اصابتان حتى الان فيه
اصابات لاطفال
في اصابات من داخل المنازل وليست في
الخارج وهناك اصابات كانوا في الشوارع
اثناء لحظه الاشتباكات هذا الموقف
الانساني ايضا
يعني محزن جدا في المستشفى عدم قدره
الكوادر الطبيه لانداد لايصال المساعدات
لهؤلاء المتضررين اتحدث عن امدادات بشكل
مستشفيات التي تصل في مثل هذه الحالات
للطوارئ من ايصال الكوادر الطبيه الكافيه
ايصال المعدات الطبيه الكافيه نسبه لعدم
وجود حركه على الاطلاق الان في الشوارع
الشوارع الان خاليه تماما من المطبخ حاليا
من العربات حاليا
الدوله نعم
نعم
في في كل انحاء العاصمه الان
تصريحات تشير الى ان الدعم السريع اصبح
خارج اطار
المؤسساتيه اذا مصحه تعبير وانه هناك
مجموعات هي التي تتحرك نحن نتحدث عن تشردم
اذا ما اردنا فقط فهم هذا التصريح ما الذي
يعني
[موسيقى]
بين الرجلين
هو امر غير الامر الواقع على الارض
الواقعه على الارض مساو جدا يعاني منه
المواطن حقيقه هذا البعض المنتشر بين
المواطنين عدد الضحايا الاصابات
الاستمراريه حتى يعني الى الان الى هذه
اللحظه ما زالت مستمره هذه الاشتباكات
مازال ذويه لاطلاق للرصاص والقنابل
والطيران الحربي وكانك في تجمع عسكريه
تماما منذ التاسعه صباحا وحتى هذه اللحظه
طيب هل وصلنا الى اجابه للسبب وراء
وصول الامور الى ما وصلت اليه الان خاصه
انه بالامس عندما نتحدث عن حميتي على سبيل
المثال وعكس ما تحدث عنه الان من وصف
للبرهان كمجرم حرب بالامس كان يقول بانه
منفتح على التفاوض والحديث مع البرهان ما
الذي حدث بين ليله وضحاها هل لدينا اجابه
هل عرفنا ما الذي حدث
نعم الان في في هذا الصباح في الاشتباك
وجدنا ان قوات الدعم السريعه اصدرت بيانا
مقتضبا جدا اتهمت فيه من الجيش بمخاجمتها
في المدينه الرياضيه وانها فقط بدات في
الدفاع عن نفسها وايضا اتهمتها في مره
بانها بدات في هجومها وهذا ما ذكر السريعه
في هذه البيانات
وتم الغدر بها دون اخطارها باي شيء وانها
فقط تدافع عن نفسها في المقابل الجيش
السوداني اذا اصدر بيان ان هذه قوه مائقه
خارجه عن القانون يجب حسمها يجب حسب هذه
التقلصات وهكذا
لم تستضح الصوره بعد في من الذي بدا هذا
الامر او ما الذي دفع لفعل هذا الامر
الواقع يقول انه الاشتباك حدث وما زال
مستمر حتى ماذا عن الرباعيه ذكر حماتي انه
تواصل معهم بغض النظر عن الروايه التي
طرحها ولكن هل من تحركات الان وهل يمكن
القول انه وصلنا الى
طلاق ما بين الرجلين كامل
نعم يمكن ان يفهم بانه الان يعني بعد هذه
الوتيره وتيره التوتر
الاشتباك الذي وصل اشتباك بالسلاح في
مختلف ولايات السودان بين قوات الدعم
السريع وبين الجيش السوداني الاتهامات
المتبادله العبارات المستخدمه التي فيها
نستطيع ان نقول لغه
ليست لغه سياسيه هي لغه اكبر من ذلك بكثير
استخدام هذه اللغه تواجه يفهم من هذا
الامر انه يصعب ان يجلس الرجلين في طاوله
واحده يصعب جدا
وبالتالي
القضيه يجب ان تكون حسم بحسب ما يرى
المراقبون
ربما لكن الحسم على الارض دائما اقول
ونكررها
بمشاهداتنا فقط كل قولنا الذي نقوله بناء
على المشاهدات التي شاهدناها في حركتنا
اثناء اليوم منذ التاسعه صباحا وحتى الان
المشاهدات التي شاهدناها على الارض البعض
لدى المواطنين عدم استيعابهم لما يحدث
حينما يكون الاشتباك بهذا الشكل وبطريقه
المواطنون لا يملكون فيها يعني لم يعد
مواطنوا الخرطوم على مثل هكذا اشتباكات في
هذا الشكل حين قوتين مدججتين بالسلاح
بشده انواع السلاح يعني درجات عاليه جدا
من السلاح استخدام مضادات داخل المدن
الطيران داخل المدن لاستخدام ايضا
المدافع القويه جدا المدافع الكبيره
والصغيره كلها بانواعها واشكالها داخل
المدن كل هذه الامور مزعجه جدا للسكان
ايضا الضحايا التفاصيل شل حركه الحياه
الان المناطق الحيويه ضربت مثل مطار
الخرطوم مثل الشوارع الرئيسيه في الخرطوم
الان كل المناطق الحيويه التي تم ضربها
وتكرار الضرب عليها وكل فتره تعليها مع
عصابه سواء كان الجيش والدعم وكل هذه
الامور تجعل من النظر الى هذا الامر انه
ليس هنالك رابح من هذه الحرب
تبعات
ستكون على الجانب الاقتصادي والاجتماعي
وغيره ولكن دعنا نتحدث قليلا عن
الاصطفافات الان الكل يندد والكل يطالب
بوقف اطلاق النار ولكن من يقف مع من بهذا
الاطار
الان بالنسبه للمواطنين على كل حال على ان
مستويات يعني المواطنون الان بالضبط هم في
حاله جعر وفي حيره من امرهم يعني
شخصيه تحدث بلغه او كل طرف يتحدث بلغه انه
ظلموا انه تم الاعتداء عليه
حملتي من جهه يتحدث على ان الجيش اعتدى
عليه وانه لا يريد تحول مدني ديموقراطي في
هذه البلاد لا يريد هذه البلاد الاستقرار
وانه كان يهدد بموضوع هذا الاستقرار وانه
يريد ان يجعلها
الديكتاتوريات وفرض الكلمه الواحده في
المقابل ايضا هناك الجيش السوداني يتحدث
عن قوه متمرده خارجه عن القانون تتحرك كما
تريد
تغيرت لغه الجيش هذا الصباح من قوه متمرده
الى سميت في اخر مره العدو
المرحله جعلت المواطن السوداني الان في
حيره من امره لكن بشكل عام
يرى انه
سالم ولكن دعنا نستمع الى كلمه رئيس
الوزراء السوداني السابق عبد الله حمدوك
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الشعب السوداني
العظيم
اخاطبكم اليوم بصفه المواطن السوداني الذي
يشفق على بلاده واهلها اخاطبكم وبلادنا
تواجه خطر التفكك واقول ان الرصاصه حين
تنفلت من السلاح لن تميز بين المعتدي وغير
المعتدي والضحايا هم السودانيون رساله
الاولى للفريق اول عبد الفتاح البرهان
وقاده الجيش السوداني وللفريق اول محمد
حمدان دقلو وغاده الدعم السريع يجب ان
يتوقف الرصاص فورا ويجب ان يحكم صوت العقل
فالخساره ستكون من نصيب الجميع ولا يوجد
منتصر على جثث شعبي رسالتي الثانيه للشعب
السوداني بان ازداد تماسكا وان يكون تلاحم
مكونات المجتمع وخطاب رفض الاحتراب والسعي
وان لا يتم السماح لصوت اذكى الحرب
بالسيطره رساله الثالثه المجتمع الاقليمي
والدولي ومحبي السلام العالمي بان يقوموا
بواجبهم في الحل وتهدئه الاطراف المتقاتله
فالحرب في السودان تعني الحرب في الاقليم
ولا يزال الحل السلمي ممكنا حفظ الله
السودان وشعب السودان
واعود لسالم الهاشمي مراسل العربيه من
الخرطوم سالم اعود اليك طبعا هناك استمعنا
الى نداء لوزير رئيس الوزراء السابق عبد
الله حمدوك يناشد بوقف ما يحدث على الارض
طبعا مناشدات ستخرج من اكثر من جهه لاشاك
ولكن هل لها تاثير برايك ما هي
الحظوه التي
يشكلها حمدوك الان
طيب يبدو اننا فقدنا سالم هل تسمعني
نعم نعم سالم استمعنا الى نداء رئيس
الوزراء السوداني السابق عبد الله حمدوك
يناشد الجهات المعنيه بالتوقف عن اطلاق
النار بالتهدئه ما مدى تاثير هذه الدعوه
والرساله من قبله على الشارع على الطرفين
ايضا
نعم ربما يفهم ايضا من حديث دكتور عبد
الله حمدوك انه فعلا تحدث بعقلانيه بانه
فعلا ليس هناك رابح في حرب المواطنين فيما
بينهم ابناء الوطن الواحد ابناء السودان
ككل ليس هنالك رابح في الاقتتال في داخل
السودان عبد الله حمدوك تمتع شعبيه جديده
ربما لانه رئيس الوزراء المدني الذي جاء
عن الثوره ولديه قاعده جماهيريه نستطيع ان
نقول انها معقوله هذه القاعده الجماهيريه
تجد تفاعلا منه حتى ان هناك حملات كانت في
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي بعيده توقيع
الاتفاق الايطالي تبحث عن عوده الرجل
كرئيس الوزراء وانه الاصلح بهذه المهمه
بحكم انه رئيس الوزراء المدني الذي جاء
بعد ثوره يرى المواطنين انها ثوره كانت
ترفع شعارات عظيمه وتبحث عن بناء سودان
بشكل مختلف ربما شعبيه الرجل تجعل من
كلمات هذه ربما ربما تجد واقعا على الاقل
عند المواطنين
هذه الكلمه لعبد الله حمدوك ولكن دعني
اشير الى الصور التي نشاهدها الان
لعمليه استيلاء الجيش على مركبات وايضا
ملابس لقوى الدعم السريع طبعا
نواصل معك سالم في هذه التغطيه والحديث عن
ردود الفعل عبد الله حمدوك قلت ان لديه
شعبيه ويمكن ان يكون لها تاثير من من
الشخصيات التي يجب ان تظهر الان والتي
يمكن ان يكون بالفعل لها الكلمه
الاعلى اذا مصحه تعبير لوقف ما يحدث الان
من اشتباكات
نعم كل الرموز السياسيه المنوط بها او
التي كانت ظاهره في المشهد السوداني في
الفتره الماضيه منوط بها ان تظهر الان لان
هذه مرحله حاسمه فعلا من حياه هذا الشعب
بمثل هذه الاحتمات هذه النزاعات بهذا
الشكل الكبير في داخل المدن بهذه الطريقه
ربما هذا الامر يذهب بالبلاد الى المنزلق
الذي كان يحذر منه العقلاء قبل انطلاق هذا
الامر يعني منذ اسابيع نحن مستمع الى
الكثير من العقلاء هم يتحدثون الى ان فتيل
هذه الازمه اذا انقرض لن يكون هنالك سودان
لن تكون هناك دوله اصلا يتم النجاح حولها
يجب ان يحكم صوت العقل ان يعود الناس الى
طاوله الحوار لوضع الحلول لهكذا لكن ظلت
هذه الوتيره تتصارع الى ان تفاجا الجميع
منهم السداري يعني اغلب السودانيون اليوم
متفاجئون فعلا في صباح هذا اليوم بم ثل
هذا الاحتلام وهذا القتال بهذا الشكل
العنيف العشوائي تماما بهذا الشكل والى
هذه اللحظه ما زلنا نسمع ذوي اطلاق الرصاص
نسمع الانفجارات بين الفين والاخرى وهناك
ايضا طائرات في الجو تظهر بين الفينه
والاخره
شكرا جزيلا لك سالم الهاشمي من مراسلنا من
الخرطوم نعود اليك حل ورود المزيد من
المعلومات معنى من الخرطوم اللواء كمال
اسماعيل رئيس حزب التحالف الوطني السوداني
اهلا بك لواء كمال بدايه قراءتكم للمشهد
وماذا تقولون بما حدث اليوم
شكرا جزيلا وناسف اسف كبير جدا جدا لما
يحدث في بلدنا السودان وفي الاحتراب
الحاصل بين ابناء السودان هذا طبعا شيء
طير يعني مقبول شيء يعني للغايه ان شعبنا
عظيم شعبنا السودان قام بيصوره عظيم طائب
الحريه والسلام والعداله يواجه باهم
الشهاده الموقف اين اخطا اين اخطا
السودانيون حتى وصلوا الى هذه المرحله
نحن نبهنا كثيرا
انه اول الحرب كلام وبيانات
حاولنا بقدر المستطاع النطفي هذه الحرب من
بدايتها من الكلام وتصريحات والبيانات
اللي هي الصاعده مثلا وحاولنا نقعد مع كل
الاطراف اختبار انه هناك مشروع سياسي وفي
ذات الاتفاق ايطالي وهناك توجه نحو الدوله
المدنيه وهناك توجه على الاستقرار السودان
بيظل هذه الاشياء كانت ممكنه مخيفه كل
الناس لكن يعني
النهارده بمساله هو ما حصل المؤسف في
بلادنا
حصل حصل
الان في معارك داخل شوارع الخرطوم وهناك
معارك في الاحياء السكنيه وهناك ضحايا من
المدنيين والعسكريين في الطرفين وهذا شيء
مؤسف جدا جدا
وراء ما حدث لانه في اكثر من نظريه نظر
نظريه تقول انه هناك من الفلول من النظام
السابق من حاولوا اشعال هذه الفتنه هناك
من يحمل المسؤوليه على البرهان بقوله بانه
يحاول احداث فوضى بالسودان لسحب
السجاده اذا مصحه تعبير من اقدام المدنيين
وهناك من يقول الدعم السريع وهو تمرد انت
ماذا تقول قراءتك لهذا المشهد
والمنطق يقول الذين هم لديهم مصلحه في عدم
الاتفاق السياسي وعدم العبور للدوله
المدنيه هم اصحاب النظام السابق في اثنين
ثلاثه لانه كل الاطراف السودانيه مدنيه
كانت ام عسكريه وقوه في هذا الاتفاق
الاطاري بقيه النقله من الشيء المؤقت الى
المدني وتقسيمه السلطه المدنيه وهذه
تصريحات اطلقتها وكل الاطراف
واحد هل هل نجحوا هل نجحوا وكيف
لا هم مش هم نجحوا الحاصل ده هو تدبير
بتاع النظام السابق عناصر الاسباب السابق
هل هم اساسا بعد ما حصل
ازالته من التمثيل تم اعادتهم في 25
اكتوبر واستلموا مسائل كثيره جدا وهدف
وانت لمتابعه او الناس الشعب السوداني
متابع كل النشاط بتاع الفلوس في الفتره
اللي فاتت كان نشاط يعني
محمي تماما
نحن من السلطه الحاكمه
لانه عم تحكي تواضع كامل عمين عم تحكي
خلينا نحكي بالاسماء ونضع النقاط على
الحروف انت تتحدث عن انه ما تم الان هو من
ضمن في اطار مؤامره كامله السلطه حاكتها
بغطاء من فلول النظام هذا ما تقوله
لا انا ما اقول كده انا بقول بانه
اقول الان نحن في الفتره اللي فاتت
والفتره اللي احنا موجودين فيها دي في
غياب
مسؤوليات دوله كامله بحيث انه حزب محلول
يتم فتح الطريق له وعدم التصدي اليهم
افتارات ويطلع يعمل فتوات بالقتل ومسائل
زي دي هي في قياس الدوله كاملا وكنا نحس
بانه هذا القيام سيؤدي لمواجهات شعبيه
لانه ما بدر بنت هو المقاومه كويس هي
حينما فشلت السلطه الحاكمه في ايقاف هذا
قامت قوه المقاومه في كاليري وقائمه في
الخرطوم باخذ المبادره لمنع الفنون من
التجمع
ين تماما ما لا يمكن تفتح
القنوات والمسائل زيدي شخص يجي يقول عايز
فتوى عشان يقتل زول عضو في الامم المتحده
وهو يعني ضيفا علينا ماذا علينا هذا
عندما تقول
تسلموا زمام المبادره هون عن مين عم تحكي
عن قوه المقاومه
الممثله بمن
الممثل بقوه المقاومه الشعبيه هذه
المقاومه التي قادت الحراك وقادت الصغرى
بما يحدث الان اين هي
الدوله اخذوا المبادره وهم واجهوا حلول
النظام في عده مناطق في السودان وهذا
مشهود ومنعوهم من التجمع لانه ده حزب
محلول بالتالي اي نشاط له نشاط معادي اي
نشاط له غير مقبول وهذا الاشياء هي السمحت
هؤلاء الفلول عايزين يريدوا بعجلها
التاريخ للخلف لكن هيهات هيهات هيهات نحن
ان نربط ما ذكرته بما يحدث الان المشهد
الحاصل الان على الارض
هم ضد الاستقرار وهم ضد الدوله المدنيه
وهم ضد الاتفاق الاداري ده هم الاعداء
الان هم تحركوا كل المسائل دي وشو هي
الخيارات الموجوده الان والسيناريوهات
المطروحه
هذه فرصه لكل الشعب السوداني بمنطلقه
الرواه السياسيه والمدنيه والنقابيه
والطلابيه وهو المقاومه ان تتوحد تماما
وتصل عامل ضغط كويس لتنفيذ كله
اهداف الثوره العظيمه لا بد من وحده كامله
وانا في المجال اشاهد نحن في قوه الحريه
التغيير عملنا بيان واردناه على اخواننا
مالك
[موسيقى]
الحرب ولا بد من ايقافه
اطلاق النار ولابد من الجلوس في التفاوض
هذا السودان ملك للجميع ليس ملك لدعم سريع
الجيش ولا ملك لينا جميعا نحن لابد انه في
وحدتنا كامله دي انه نكون عنصر الضغط
ومقيس مع شعبنا واهدافه مبادئ الثوره
العظيمه اللي قامت فان هذه المقالب ما هذا
لن الا اذا كان استجابه
لوقف اطلاق النار ومن ثم تعني نحن الكثير
من الاحيان قعدنا مع كل الاطراف وناخذ
تاكيدات انه ما في
لا تنفوجين لكن انا عسكري سابق كنت متوقع
الناس بيقول لك مفاجاه ما كنت مفاجاه لانه
متوقعي لانه اول ما قلت لك كلام كلام
بيانات وحاجات كثيره جدا وفلول شغالين
بيتكلموا هناك ويعملوا مواكب وبيعملوا
حاجات وده كله
لانه في
سؤال
رئيس حزب التحالف الوطني السوداني شكرا
جزيلا لك
والمزيد ايضا معنا من الخرطوم الكاتب
الصحفي محمد عبد العزيز اهلا بك بدايه اي
معلومات متوفره لديك حول الامور واين وصلت
حتى الان على الارض
طيب يبدو انه السيد محمد غير جاهز دعونا
نشاهد هذه المقاطع الجديده التي وصلتنا من
السودان تظهر قصف جوي في سماء العاصمه
طبعا في اطار الاشتباكات بين الجيش
السوداني وطبعا قوات الدعم السريع
المتابعه
[موسيقى]
ومشاهدينا معنا من الخرطوم الاستاذ محمد
عبد العزيز الصحفي اهلا بك استاذ محمد
بدايه هل لك ان تعطينا فكره عن اي معلومات
متوفره لديك حول ما يحدث على الارض الان
او اي تصريحات جديده
اسعد الله مساكم بكل خير لدي الكثير من
المعلومات انا في منطقه ام درمان في الجزء
الشمال الغربي من العاصمه الخرطوم
هناك انقطاع للتيار الكهربائي اصوات
الرصاص ما تزال مستمره منذ الساعه الحاديه
عشره صباحا في منطقه منطقه عسكريه في شمال
اي منطقه تضم عدد من الوحدات والمواصفات
العسكريه تتوفر معلومات تفصيليه لكن
اشتباكات ما تزال مستمره في هذه الناحيه
من العاصمه في انقطاع للتيار الكهربائي
هذا ينطبق على كافه المناطق او مناطق
بعينها
ليس كافه المناطق مناطق محدوده
حسب المتابعات الاشتباكات لا تختصر فقط
على العاصمه ولكن تمتد الى عده مدن اخرى
في شركه السودان في بورسودان او حتى في
المناطق الشماليه او في دارفور والتي
تجددت بكثافه بعد الساعه الثانيه ظهرا
خاصه في منطقه في مدينه الفاشر وفي مدينه
نيالا الاشتباكات تتواصل حسب المعلومات
التي تتواتر الينا لكن انا شخصيا ليست
لديه تفاصيل عن اخر مجالات الاحداث خاصه
ان هناك حاله من المعلومات المضلله
الكثيفه التي يتم تداولها على مواقع
السوشيال ميديا وعلى المنصات الاعلاميه
تتحدث كل طرف عن سيطرته على موقع
استراتيجيه ولكن من الواضح ان الشبكه
الشيء المؤكد حتى الان على الاقل عن
الاشتراكات ما تزال مستمره وانه ميدان
المعركه من المبكره ان يحسم هذا اليوم
سؤال ذكرت انه في انقطاع للتيار الكهربائي
او لا
التيار الكهربائي في بعض الاجزاء من العصر
الخرطوم في بعض الاحياء في سبب محدد بسبب
الاشتباكات او هذا امر
هل تمت تعطيل محطات او غيرها لا احد يعلم
ولكن التيار الكهربائي معطل في بعض
الاحيان ليست كل المناطق
اخرى
طيب ليست لديك معلومات او مصدر للمعلومات
لنتعرف اكثر عما يحدث ولكن من قراءتك
للمشهد الى اين تتجه الامور
من النصف نقول انه الامور تتجه الان الى
سيناري واشبح بلال الحرب الاهليه الصراع
الذي بدا اليوم من الممكن ان لا ينتهي
لسنوات
هو صراع الذي يمتد
الدعم السريع والجيش ويمكن ان تكون لده
داعيات جهويه
ويغلية
تستند على الطائره او تستند على مجموعه
اخرى
فما يجعل اسرار يعني يستمر الى سنوات
طويله من الواضح جدا ان المعركه ستتحول
خلال الساعات القادمه الى حذف شوارع
وهذه يعني ممكن تكون جزء من تفاصيل
المعركه الكبرى ولكن اذا تحدثنا على انه
هذه المعركه هي معركه لا تنتهي بالضرب
القاضي هي معركه تنتهي بحساب النقاط فيمكن
ان تخسر في الخرطوم وتكسب في نيالا او
تخسر في نيالا او تكسب فيقول هناك معركه
شامله لا تحتفظ على العاصمه ولكن تمتد الى
كل حدود السودان وهو يشير الى انه نحن
امام معركه طويله ستستمر يعني من الممكن
اذا لم يتم الاحتكام الى صوت ان تستمر الى
سنوات هل سيسمح للسودان ان ينجر الى حرب
اهليه وخاصه انه احنا على المستوى
الاقليمي هناك توجهات
لنوع من المصالحه والتهدئه ما بين الدول
الم يكون هناك زخم ربما اقليمي للدفع
بالسودان نحو التهدئه
التحشيد الذي يعني الذي وصل الى مرحله
المواجهه العسكريه مباشره اليوم يعني تم
تحديد منه لتربيع طويله كانت هناك العديد
من الدعوات للتحذير من الوصول الامور الى
موصل اليه الان هناك وفاطات محليه من قوى
سياسيه مدنيه وهناك وساقطات من
ودعوات من اقليميه ودوليه هذه الوصفات
كانت مستمره حتى فجر اليوم يعني الساعه
الواحده صباحا كان هناك لقاء مع غايه
الجيش السيد عبد الفتاح البرهان من
المنتظر ان يكون هناك لقاء اخر مع غايه
الدعم السريع محمد حمدان ده كانوا في
الساعه العاشره من صباح اليوم ولكن من
الواضح انه فتيل الازمه اشتعلت بفعل عناصر
النظام السابقه التي بحسابات الواقع هي
المستفيده الاكبر هذا السيناريو الجميع
حذر منه والتحدث عنه قبل قبل اسابيع طويله
وقبل شهور ان هناك محاولات لاشعال الحرب
والصدام ما بين الدعم السريع والجيش وهي
حرب وضع لن تنتهي في في ايام او في اسابيع
كيف وقع القاده بمثل هذا الفخ اذا كان من
قبل فلول النظام السابق
هناك حاله من التعبئه هناك اختلاف البدل
الامر بشكل اساسي اختلاف في التصورات
والمواقف من العمليه السياسيه ومن مسار
الفتره الانتقاليه الواضح ان الطرفين
لديهم مطامع ولديهم مخاوف وهي متفاوته
ومتباينه التقاعد ادارتها بطريقه مختلفه
مما انعكس على مساله
تناقض او تباين المصالح وظهر ذلك بشكل
واضح منذ مارس بان تم الاعلان عنه بشكل
واضح منذ حيث ظهرت التصريحات التي تشير
الى حاله
الشقاق او حاله عدم الاتفاق بين فائده
الدعم السريع وغايه
الجيش وظهر ذلك انه حتى التصريحات اشاره
لانه منذ انقلاب 25 اكتوبر اتبعت الشرطه
بين الطرفين وبعد ان مصالح كل طرف متباينه
عن الطرف الاخر
اذا نحن نتحدث
اذا ما استفادوا سيستفيدوا من هذا الشق
الموجود ما بين الطرفين او لديهم قوه اخرى
قادره على الحراك على الارض
طبعا هم المستفيده الاكبر التخلص من قائد
قوات الدعم السريع في المرحله الاولى واذا
اذا يعني حسب المخطط وحسب السيناريو اذا
استطاعوا للتخلص
لاحقا للتخلص من غايه الجيش نفسه والعوده
الى السوق الاخرى وحتى اذا اذا تمكنوا
يمكن ان يبطشوا بالمدنين ويقوموا بعمليات
احتفال او اختيار او غيرها من الامور
يتمكن من العوده الى السلطه ولكن تتحدث
وكانه لديهم ارضيه خصبه وحاضنه موجوده ان
كان بالجيش او بالردع السريع هل هذا هو
الواقع
وهو فعليا لديه موجود في الوطن النظاميه
موجودين على مستوى الجيش على مستوى الدعم
السريع على مستوى القوات الامنيه الاخرى
لديهم وجود واضح ومعروف يعني من يتحمل
مسؤوليه بقاء هذا الوجود استاذ محمد
العسكري كلها سواء في الدعم السريعه
والجيش لتتحمل مسؤوليه مع وسط اوضاعنا هي
تتحمل المسؤوليه لانها اخطات لم تنتبه
تغاضت ام لانها ارادت
ارادت وراتت امام اعينها يعني نوع من
الفساد بس حابه افهم يعني المشكله هي في
التقديرات يعني لم يغيروا الامور بمعايير
موضوعيه لم يستطيعوا قراءه المشهد بشكل
واقعي
الاوزان الحقيقيه لهذه المجموعات كما انهم
لم يغلبوا صوت الحكمه ويتجاوز
ان تسيطر من الخرطوم الكاتب الصحفي محمد
عبد العزيز شكرا جزيلا لك ومشاهدينا بهذا
نكون قد نهينا هذه الساعه ولكن التغطيه
مستمره
وشكرا للمتابعه ميسون نواهب تكون معكم على
راس الساعه مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات